this fog of death will cloak the land
and those men who are not prepared to
will succumb to its foul clutches for
God shows no mercy on those who heed not
his words thus will the end come and the
world made unworthy in his eyes will be
purified by black angels so that he may
be given you
you
only compounded Gemma station oh he's
unless you I'm and let you some B's
behind you his zombies behind you go
just
alright
I would not want to be in the
underground when zombies around it's
like yo escape okay wait best friends Oh
machine wow great can I jump ah my
head's in the way of all the words all
right once a passionate wait where am i
what am i doing am I on the floor no
okay okay oh I feel safe here it's nice
can I just stay in here okay oh what's
that nail first r32 you to torch hold
our three in total use your flash there
okay Oh Lee empty date you empty and
scary there's the underground is that
the ant or tube map Waterloo station and
stomach how do this I feel I feel I can
relate okay okay how do we kill them
gather that me
oh hi okay go go go enter already creepy
I love it because I'm always prepared
and we're with the pain is he a Brummie
I knew this was coming a long time I
know a succession I didn't really very
large on the work then yes oh I'm we're
listening to anything okay sorry turn
office wasting it save oh I'm gonna
sleep find the previous survivor well
where are they supposed to be I thought
he said that they went outside am I
supposed to go outside because I thought
him to tell me how to guys like what was
that yeah cool gone make up the cookie
bat don't be squeamish
the other known spoken agreement between
survivors because if you go infected to
do the same for you nasty business but
he's got to be doing now check that bold
[ __ ] is your best me a pistol and I'm oh
you're definitely gonna need yeah good
let's do this okay hmm sorry Bob give me
a sec I'll be on those shutters oh cool
[ __ ] you got incoming check your radar
lebanon check me right up guys I don't I
don't like this job till I'm ready I'm
ready for it guys are you ready for it
cuz I'm ready for it uh-huh hate the
noise ok I'm ready for you I'm going to
hit you oh my god you're huge ok you
know that be oh I got a soda wicked out
at this radar it's like I'm yo in front
hill and you can hear them coming with
the crackle so you're not ever too
scared where you are ah but you know you
know when it's gonna be there ah i
finally got the key cut off
laughs who won this tells me here oh he
felt in my handiwork a long time ago our
team to with a buncha no hope it's
called the Ravens estate I helped them
for teeth are places like this because
we knew this was coming you know creepy
rat that zombies gone did you see the
red dot before it's gone now oh my gosh
guys it's so dark exit can you guys hear
that noise it's extremely unsettling I
don't want to it's nothing in a dumpster
I was just gonna climb on it and then
climb up the wall it's in my ears is it
in your ears are you wearing headphones
where am I going I don't know okay we're
away from the noises things are better
here sure you kill this guy yeah I know
oh god finish him huh sorry I go crazy
psycho boy I need to kill things yeah
there's a manhole nearby vysya quickies
way back to the sear house have a gander
sometimes retreat is your best option
okay garland work soldier Thanks hey I
was in bricklaying this weekend you're
twisting uh let's go there wait where am
I supposed to get no it's where I'm
supposed to go yeah oh my god got it
triangular Julia it's inside the
supermarket be careful oh I didn't want
to do that oh my god is way too dark I
hate it use your radar you have to pee
areas manually if you want to know
what's lurking in your blind spot you're
the ladder
zombie crow that's my son we scream I've
actually been trained as a zombie do you
guys know that you think I could jump
done okay this is a rad there's one
walking but this one fooling so I think
I think we can do this it's not too much
let's do this let's get the walking one
Hey hi friends now you know you oh my
god there's something by my me I finish
you I finish I before every flight at
the mall oh my god ok not right that way
oh my god
oh my god those poor coppers were
probably responding to the supermarket
alarm but they've got bigger problems
now okay um I've got problems like how
do I drink my soda oh this is not good
room to be in oh my god not appreciate
this shiza oh god please dumb Bell okay
[ __ ] oh my god go away mama you're gonna
need to rid the planks off some doors no
no no I need to find out how to here we
go ah that's so much belly some cake
Kate makes life better hello oh my god
finish
no what gets finished you do i get back
home after I kill you Oh though you're
already does is this too oh god i hate
you all this Oh Gary it's cool I can do
there's another one I'm not thought I
know it's another one lalalalalalalala
ah toys oh how cool do they let guys
little gremlins dad yeah I want I would
buy oh yeah knew there was a zombie
close that door
oh why do I go boil em mash em stick em
sue boy who said that rubber boiler
mushroom signals do Oh dedos well date
is what when you goin in box Ling the
pad up to bring the cameras back on line
oh I love all their regulars on the
stream love it oh sorry I did not see
that coming though I just came this way
and everything was fine did he fool down
oh oh my god that was not fun good two
hours well cook you passed earlier and
get you a spot do they say about in one
piece no it's not gonna work is gonna be
hard Oh guys oh nice and easy noise two
races which way not that way wait where
do I come from this way yeah
whoa oh my god oh my god finish it
finish him go down this prick you think
sorry pitch me I was like I just thought
the ones i clicked on the manhole they
would pause the game okay he gets one
coming on You Man be back now you may
have noticed a box in the main room with
a raven symbol on it time to show you
how it works okay shite and not before
time there's a hold approaching check
your radar where are they where are they
shiza hey you're so angry headshot
oh my god i don't like I am NOT hey I
did not say you could come into my home
no just bugger off you know welcome here
hey where it was come on is to hey get
your ass down don't do this you don't
want to do this oh my god Pete you know
the vamoosh intelligence left I've gotta
go home to the instinct like an animal
and that our thing to them not your
neighbor your friend your relatives
they're all dead and those things
wearing their faces are not human okay
nah we do some nice music sweet it's
funny because they actually does sound
like the guy he talks in the underground
mind the gap please stand clear of the
doors there's always someone squeezing
themselves on the tube like a sardine
with a little bag getting stuck in the
doorway hello
you never know i'm not i'm not doing
this for the fun of it I'm doing it to
be to be sober the guy sounds like Atlas
and bioshock no Atlas ism is Irish this
guy's English would you kindly pick up
that school driver for it
good thing about both policy it's not
just a building it's a fortress a highly
secure location you can bet your office
top out guns and ammo like nobody's
business yeah yeah anything to just get
rid of all the zombies inside then they
should be able to get in from outside oh
I'm blow vows a lot of blood oh my god
good reason finish it hate the noises
and what being scary without those
reckon noise this is scary there should
be a zombie on the other side of the
bars and say oh did you see that look at
this look on the map they're everywhere
else is not really fun
nah I know United buddy I know not dead
funny hmm where are you oh I think I
just got no kiddie only a few zombie
still too many spy it's fine I'm glad
you're all so positive about this oh are
you positive of this though look how
creepy that it's won't you oh ok where
are they is so freaky I even know where
I'm looking ok what is that why is that
just shining on me shame me what oh my
god it's so dark Aizen ok it's literally
pitch black I ate it okay this is what
I'm supposed to be going darn it I don't
need to go oh come completely the wrong
way to thing one up here did we oh ok
we also went in I don't saw the freaking
chance
so scared right now don't even oh my god
thanks
okay but ah we let this prick again
don't do this [ __ ] yo okay go cuz it up
the dough okay right um do things there
you go no no [ __ ] I think this one
here oh ok oh my god quite a little yoga
number go oh wait to do some helps when
you think about rights to all else do
the family over here go go go go yeah I
don't know me know I floppy I 2,000
rounds that good but the establishment
lucha okay go go go go go go go go go go
go oh my god you're gone oh I knees
gonna come back out oh sorry guys very
button
I think around the fire the gun oh don't
come from behind me that's the Sheep
shop in it didn't poop oh my god guys
look I can't just ah that's so nice
whatever okay
no no no no no no no okay thank you
where's that opening twist me here or
something screw it screw it because I
got see go go run this way No
I don't know what you know what always
vote by the [ __ ] time I just ran away
I'm pretty sure there's an old Raven
shelter nearby I find what you need down
there
school we can use a spankin on it's
closed or we can chill let's chill this
game this game is getting me okay it's
good that I'm rendering it let's try and
get back to us I'll rather home shall we
oh my god okay I sticks around I was so
happy without falling
are you ready to sing to it